Trunked radio is how hundreds of user
groups share a handful of frequencies — by
never owning any of them.
Here is the problem it solves.
Under conventional radio, every group gets
its own fixed frequency.
Police dispatch is always on channel A.
Fire is always on channel B.
Public works is always on channel C.
Simple — but wasteful, because most of the
time, most of those channels are silent.
Radio traffic is bursty.
Any one group transmits only a small
fraction of the time, and groups rarely
all key up at once.
A city with thirty groups on thirty
frequencies is paying for thirty channels
and using maybe four of them in any given
second.
Trunking flips the model.
Take a small pool of channels — say five —
and let a computer hand them out on
demand.
When someone keys up, their radio asks for
a channel.
A coordinator called the control channel
picks a free one, announces the
assignment, and every radio in that user's
group retunes to it together.
When the talker is done and a hang timer
expires, the channel goes back into the
pool for the next call.
No group owns a frequency anymore.
What a group owns is an identity — a
talkgroup — and the system finds a
physical channel for each call, one call
at a time.
The reason this works is pure statistics —
the same queuing theory that lets a
telephone exchange serve a whole city with
far fewer lines than subscribers.
Traffic engineers measure offered load in
erlangs and size the pool so that the
probability of a call finding every
channel busy — the grade of service —
stays low.
If it ever happens anyway, the system
queues the request or plays a busy tone.
The payoff is dramatic: a well-sized pool
of five channels can comfortably serve
dozens of talkgroups that would each have
demanded a permanent frequency under the
conventional model.
The idea comes in several shapes.
FDMA systems like P25 Phase 1 give each
call its own frequency.
TDMA systems like DMR and TETRA split each
frequency into timeslots, so one channel
carries two or even four calls at once.
And a single site can stand alone, or be
linked with others into a wide-area
network covering a whole state.
We will meet all of these later in the
course.
For a scanner, trunking changes
everything.
You cannot just park on one frequency,
because the conversation you care about
scatters across the pool, call by call.
GopherTrunk deals with this the same way
the radios do: it decodes the
coordinator's announcements and follows
each call to wherever it lands — which
means one software-defined radio can
reconstruct every conversation on the
system at once.
So: trunked radio shares a small pool of
channels among many groups.
A computer assigns a free channel to each
call and takes it back afterward.
And what a group keeps is not a frequency
but an identity.
The full write-up is linked below.